what's the beef look it's weird to hate
someone because they're trans right but
it's also weird to love someone because
they're trans shouldn't you like them
based on who they are as a person
content of the character people are so
phony I love Caitlyn Jenner why she
sucks
she's against gay marriage ran over
person what's the good part
then they go well they have hard lives
all right well so do midgets
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag I don't
see any tweets about midgets who's got
harder than a minute hard to get around
hard to drive hard to get work no love
and look I'm not anti-trans but I am
pro-mage